Jesus get its Jesus cut hello there to
reject nation I'm Greg Alba look who's
returned with me today what's her name
say it's a cat Alvarado cat Alvarado
back in town she knew her own name can
you believe it we are gonna do today a
try not to get scared challenge
apparently it's super hard this is from
the channel super David gangster okay I
did like that transit scare challenge
years ago so it's been a long time for
this specific video cat and I are gonna
rock some headphones and we change up
some of the lighting to make it a little
bit more immersive for ourselves now
before we watch this though you got to
tell you guys cats podcasts villains of
history blowing off the charts right now
just had Jamie Kennedy on there recently
that was cool but you know who it's
better than that she had me on recently
we talked about the Gainesville Ripper
and the guy who inspired the Amityville
Horror stories that's really fun and I
fixed the audio yes good audio I was on
there before audio not so great but this
time audio impeccable but if you wanted
to hear about a whole bunch of real-life
daddies from the past
dictators murderers leaders yeah it's
all fun listen with your family we know
ones from the past yeah listen to this
podcast what are you a rapper are you a
rapper okay you're one of them rappers
oh I'm gonna pass it's no problem don't
hide in the comments don't shoot
yourself what [ __ ] wait I hope it's not
too loud okay turn it down no don't get
scared
right
[Music]
so real level 2 so we past level one
high five gifts and he stopped feeling
girl heard her mom yeah her name down
step so she got and started to head down
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
that's so sad
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
it suddenly becomes a time that's cool
[Music]
[Music]
talking to a theme park
[Applause]
[Music]
be terrifying
I want to look away don't I know this is
gonna be this hi this is that's true
this is the challenge I can't look away
somehow this is the scariest one I
[Music]
failed the challenge this one is
terrifying
I got scared like two minutes how do
they feel that the last one this is
gonna turn into a thing huh banjo oh no
it's over okay we just waited here for
like 45 seconds is he gonna do something
hey hit me halfway through the rules of
the challenge try not to get scared I'm
like but could I just fake that if I
isn't scared as an emotion it's like you
know you guys can see whether yeah just
be like I'm not scared yeah but you
could really be scared internally you
know so I feel like I had to play it
fair if I'm feeling a little scared to
kind of like let it out a little bit
because I had to be fair to the
challenge
I mean if it's like try not to scream or
try not to jump you know yeah then
that's something that you guys can
physically see but you can't see inside
of our emotions by inside of my heart no
no don't point in that direction yeah
there's a lot of male demographic don't
look at me
I do get unnerved by pictures and these
weird gifts like this gif of the girl
that one was the first one that was a
little unnerving for sure I mean he has
turns around your reflection doesn't
move that's always a good horror movie
trick that always ropes up when the
reflection doesn't move terrifying
we seen this movie mama no I haven't
this thing this short film yeah I was
less scared than I was upset
this was upsetting Oh like because this
person lost her mom yeah yeah that was
sad I know just like watch someone like
lose their parent and be like torn apart
by a monster Garon
no because it's animated like really I
actually got pretty scared when I was
watching it pretty freaked out by though
like shutter speed that they do with it
would you call by binary not binary I
don't know but I felt empathy for this
non-binary person that's really saying
yeah yeah because it's not it's not a
little girl that's what you said keep
politics out of my try not to get scared
challenges but this last one though I
thought was super cool man
that was a trip that was done really
well the visuals were very upsetting
yeah did it scare you
did it scare me not till the very end
seeing that police officers walking up
and then just eats him yeah all right
something like that I'm just more like
smile at and I go wow look how awesome
these visuals are because it's clearly
not real like it's so hyper edited when
it breaks the reality thing that's what
makes it the most the most least as what
makes it the least scary yeah I feel
like if we were watching this whole
video and then that started happening
then it probably would have been scary
with the whole context but without the
whole context and you just kind of cut
to this moment it's not so scary this
last one looks like it looks like a
1980s horror movie or you know scared me
because of the anticipation that's what
that's a great call yes
waiting for something horrible to happen
and then it doesn't happen yet somehow
that is what worked on me the most I
don't know what that says about me I
don't know I also don't know why I said
it that way I feel like it
[Laughter]
what is that bad I don't know what it's
supposed to say about you for the fact
that your anticipation is with scare see
the most anxiety mm-hmm
let me treat it for that no we should
talk about that off-camera prescribe
something for me I know some people on
the black market that could help you out
a little bit can't don't you worry all
right well I think we overall passed it
we didn't get terrified yeah it's like
to get a little bit scared just one
thing but I mean come on they said this
is a super hard challenge super hard
I'd say mildly challenged mild sauce all
right mild salsa and a little Cayenne to
that yeah I'm honestly out of salsa of
all the different sauces I'd say this
was tomato this was the kind you put in
spaghetti this isn't something you put
on a burrito
let's not insult the guy - you still
went out of his way to put this together
you know all right Jesus cat hey I love
spaghetti sauce it's great I eat it on
pizza
pizzas Marik this was marinara you gotta
stick to an opinion all right you guys
can subscribe to the real rejects and
we'll hey seriously it's not easy
finding all this footage and compiling
it so subscribe to super David gangster
when you can't click our notification
bell cat check out her podcast villains
of history to hear about real-life
villains from the past go listen to that
podcast needs me one more syllable
therefore to work thank you guys
you know who's a podcast who the guy
from Mean Girls
do you know do you know his name
Daniel friends AC yeah I don't know the
Mean Girls he's the guy who comes up she
doesn't even go here that one that one
okay nevermind awesome fail awesome he
should have been mentioned first you're
gonna edit this out huh nope it's all
over video now all right